thank you to Harry's and expressvpn for
sponsoring more on them after the
reaction citizens of the reject Nation I
am joined with Andrew Gordon today for a
movie that I don't know anything about
it whenever I hear anyone talk about it
they really like it a lot and we've
gotten a lot of recommendations for us
from you guys you sexy citizens it's
called bottoms Andrew you excited the
bottom of my heart I am so excited Greg
well done well done I'm a
bottom my wife likes me saying that
anyway guys uh what do you guys think of
this movie do you recommend it leave
your thoughts down below be sure to
leave a like on this video that'd be
very much appreciated subscribe click
that Bell cuz we got a lot more coming
up for you this year thank you to
prepper for editing down these
highlights here's a hard R best of luck
to you with that in mind YouTube this is
all fake performed by professional cast
and crew and thank you to our super sexy
reject for joining our patreon page over
there you get the full length Reaction
watch line where you sync up with your
own copy of bottoms John and I cover
several things over there exclusively
with highlights and watchs included Andy
let's get to the bottom of
this night okay we've looked like [__]
for years and we are developing I would
say I'm actually mostly developed Black
Jesus we're getting out there we're
getting in the cooch my girl we are
getting in the
p
[Laughter]
I'm going to talk to Britney I think
that it's time oh really it's time there
wasn't time in the last 11 years we open
going to school together I'm not doing
that with Isabelle you know what I mean
like I I'm playing the long game with
her with the long game I don't speak to
the [__] for years bam it's the 20th
High School
reunion she's washed up I mean Jeff has
run her ragged that's when my ass swoop
in that made me so sad what hey it's
romantic do you want to be the only girl
virgin at Sarah Lawrence yeah honestly
maybe I might have a good shot that
way what the are you
wearing what are you doing you're get
you're getting nervous because of how
excited you know kind of getting a super
bad vibe from these two but female
version yeah they have really good
chemistry already I don't even know who
they are this school has such a gay
problem okay no no one hates this for
being gay ver us for being gay
untalented and ugly you two aren't
ugly oh my God is that your love in is
that the girl I think it's the girl hey
guys hi Hazel how was your summer were
you with your uncle at the slot Farm if
you mean volunteering at the national
meat Association slot F what happened to
your arm oh my God she [__] is what
happened oh skateboarding did you go to
juvie yeah we went to juvie oh my God it
was
juie
let's hear it
for this got like an 80s vibe to it hey
Britney DJ I am loving all the holes in
your
pants so Brit can I call you Brit I'd
prefer if you just called me my name
brittin brittin I'm going to say
something crazy I think you could eat
food digest it let it marinate poop it
out yeah that's a gross you want to buy
this oh no yeah this is
[Music]
disgusting yeah we could get the bun up
you could have get the
bun this is so well
edited Isabelle Josie was just saying
something similar to me I don't think so
I think so spill it up you're just so
you're skinny too as
well this is not awkward at all yeah
you're skinny you're a real skinny mini
aren't you
so awkward oh call the doctor skinny
girl I
see what the [__] was that I'm done
trying to sew my damn oats I'm packing
up my and I'm at you the man and cuz
he's gay and fearless he's probably
without protection then I'm going to get
pregnant
my it's actually cool to see a movie
like this from from from the women by
the way our son Hezekiah hates us cuz he
knows we're both closeted we try to make
it work for him but he's not happy and
yeah guess what the deacons the
Evangelist I don't want to live like
that will you come and visit us on
[Laughter]
Su the escalation man my teeny tiny baby
girl got why do you always have to FLIR
with other women offer her a ride
yes come on on stop you're hurting my
head you're attacking me and it's giving
me a migraine woo gaslighter Isabelle
would you like a safety
ride
Isabelle get out of the car you can't
tell me what to do yeah no you
can't sorry that I looked at Mrs Riley
and lightly grazed her left all right oh
jerk excuse me she should move prick
don't talk to me you ugly [__]
I do not talk to girls in overalls okay
I might be ugly but these aren't
overall run them over
drive just drive go no
no
stupid rather capture this like an
action movie there's such like an
attention the music and stuff and I love
the subversion making you think they
we're going to hit a at a faster speed
it's so overly dramatic what did you do
to
him and she just reversed in the first
place not going to get
[Laughter]
away what is this
film oh her was just so cute are they
the most hated kids they hit the
football star that sounds like it she's
like no not just maybe but not the bun
it was really sweet the way they talk
sounds so natural doesn't it like they
just sound like people I got number two
this time you're the sidekick not me up
has a family yeah you know what to do
they're just so used to it hey
zoie
hi romance are you guys okay what yeah
the Paras right now oh my God is in jail
all right check it out is that marshan
Lynch yeah I think so he's like a
football player comedian yeah hey you
overall [__] this is
you stupid this is principal Myers with
an important Huntington update last
night outside the fair a Huntington
player followed me home pinned me
against my car and punched me in the
face what oh great more violence just
what this school needs it's like
breaking the fourth wall
interesting I heard you like beat up my
boyfriend last night um you were you
were there I heard you guys ate literal
[__] and killed girls in juie what did
you think about that oh my God they're
they're going to feed into their
reputation ugly untalented gay please
report to the principal's office guess
that's you guys you know why you're here
I don't actually for committing a crime
against Jeff our our quarterback and the
most good-looking All-American
red-blooded muscular man this town has
ever seen look how tidy he looks do you
know how long we've been working toward
this yes yes it's everywhere 20
years he tried to murder us how come you
can't learn to protect yourselves
without running somebody El maybe it's
because we're small we needed to use a
little Machinery did you ever think of
that sir can we just explain our bu a
gun what word did you jump to this
conclusion we're just practicing
for where you getting at where are you
getting at for a self-defense Club
that's like a Fight Club yeah can't talk
about it yes a Fight Club are they
actually going to start one now beat
each other up and [__] no we don't no we
don't shut up okay you know what I don't
care
[__] yeah you can beat the [__] out of
each other just stay in your lane until
you're mching biebert Wesley yes sir
well they're going to have to start one
now right I can't believe they're
letting you guys start a fight club
we're going to do it oh oh okay they
actually are you heard the announcements
girls are terrified it's perfect they
need this I love this satire genre blend
of the way this movie is shot it's like
shot with real composition guys do that
all the time okay that's the point of
feminism that's not the point of
feminism you also don't care about
feminism your favorite show is Entourage
great show great show you guys probably
girls in juvie no we were lying about
that
obviously I'll bring Stella Rebecca you
know Stella Rebecca Stella Rea who
models at on the
weekend okay great well then bring her I
can't tell all the time what's
improvised and what's scripted it's just
too sharp it's really sharp we build a
community we Bond we're punching each
other adrenaline is Flowing next thing
you know Isabelle and britty are kissing
us on the MS
Josie it's it not even hurt we just run
the risk of becoming even bigger losers
than we already are right now how much
bigger of losers could you be just do it
at the bottom we the the lowest of we
have no to go up said bottoms there's a
serious lack of female solidarity at
this school not not the point Hazel yeah
I mean we just felt like there's a
serious lack of female solidarity at
this what's your plan here I don't need
a plan my mom has a business all he have
to do is yell it's like a weird film but
it's also a Coming of Age story I guess
in that way makes it kind of like an '
80s movie what the these girls are ugly
where is Stella she was booked for a car
convention you got to build the
reputation thanks for the invite I love
David
Fincher yes cat references
self-awareness listen up you un sucking
pieces of
[__] to our
CL Huntington is on the prow so we're
going to teach you how to not take [__]
we're going to start with drop kicks do
they know how to fight and we punch you
until you bleed before that perhaps
stretches is ice
breaker I'm her JY was way crazier one
time this girl's punching me in the Rain
Fall to my
knees punch her right in the middle of
her face broke nose Josie cared her
share she delivered that with conviction
juvie was
insane once a girl tried to kill me with
rat poison so I took her outside and I
punched her till she died so you killed
a girl no the ambulance came and revived
her and we actually had a really
productive conversation
since Josie literally killed a girl she
came back to it she's like the Michael
Sarah Josie is going to start by showing
you all how to effectively throw a solid
punch Josie if you'll step forward why
would you pass that to her come on they
want to see the punch they don't want to
see it they want to see look at
them punch me punch you yeah come on I
can punch you yeah I know how to take a
punch something people would always say
PJ knows how to take a punch come on
up
oh Jesus Christ what just
happened
[Music]
oh [__] who's going to be dumb enough to
endorse a club where we punch each other
in the
face the Holocaust it happened yes it
did but how yes it did it was just so
great and I was I was thinking like if
Huntington and me were in an alleyway oh
she's looking and you told me how to
punch like that then I wouldn't die but
unfortunately Josie doesn't want to do
the club anymore why just so empowering
what was oh my God hi
uh Fight Club is our fight club for um
female solidar at this school female
Fight Club go let's go
hi I'm so strong it's such a pathetic
man Mr G hey uh girl thanks for coming
in today we have to come in it's class
like that book He's reading divorced and
happy try telling Demetri Walker that
little mother came the first week and I
ain't seen him since Demetri Walker
commits the first week of school sure he
did wondering if you wanted to be our
club advisor it's a Women's Club we talk
about women's issues oh periods
declining Ed
count
why don't you just ask one of the female
teachers thought about that but we hate
them makes sense can I be honest you're
a man who's not coping with what's going
on yeah you know what my mom did say I
need to pick up a hobby
and
inappropriate you can be our club
adviser you don't even come to the dang
club by the way great way to be an ally
that's my favorite way to be an ally you
just say you're doing something and you
don't do any of those
things
this is the world I'll sign off on your
period Club really okay all right period
Club It Is There Will Be Blood okay
excuse me sorry I feel sorry
um there's such Polar Opposites the two
main leads I love it this isn't a little
hangout I feel like this movie is going
to get so violent there's serious rules
that we need to establish first we don't
talk about this listen second be on time
these are good rules Club starts at 3:15
the doors close at
3:15 I don't care if you're like oh but
I have to go to extra help for math
because except when my mom lives in a
trailer and she those two can come at
any which time my dad left me and I'm
incredibly
punctual what the hell did she just say
um hey guys come on
in we're going to start with some body
contact I think I need a volunteer
Britney you're close to
me I thought we weren't allowed to be
late that's not true oh that's about um
next week so the rules for next week
don't be late but this week is good
wores late I thought this was to be part
of like a local underprivileged female
Community my identity is completely
attached to her so I just kind of go
wherever she
goes everyone's here for a good reason
so you know like what why are
we reason how the variation of colorful
personalities is really well constructed
you just use your Natural Instincts just
come at me whatever you want
okay oh God that's great I say that we
go again oh oh [__] man we got to shut
this
down you know this is a little messy
right now but
like we can learn how to defend
ourselves is by teaching each other
Huntington is coming it's fair fair for
game I know that things might seem scary
but that's okay because because because
you're going to be Pros is what I was
going to say yeah uhhuh Crystal I'm
thinking of you you are never going to
get assaulted on your birthday again
lucky number
seven I'm going to finally reverse stalk
my stalker yeah yeah I'll be able to
kill my
stepdad what it just got really dark
let's do this yeah yeah yeah yeah who's
the black girl I've I've seen her a lot
lately on like so think she was at the
Oscars or something or something the
main one yeah she was in what's that
show I'll figure it out it's with the
actor from Shameless I forgot what the
show's called but she's been she just
hosted and she was in she was April
O'Neal and T Ninja Turles the animated
one we reacted
[Applause]
to you're clearly swinging above the
head oh ouch
ouch
[Music]
Jesus oh my
God oh my God whatever makes you feel
empowered I
[Applause]
guess
no nice oh they're fighting each other
oh my God headbutt keep it
up see that the doing the Bane
hey
oh got some romantic tension God stop
smiling I'm kicking your
[Laughter]
ass yeah talk to
her oh man these girls are toughening
up you little [__] it's actually
working I told you
they're starting to be like this is
crazy this is so insane to have a safe
space like this it means a lot to people
and I think that if we took some time to
spend a meeting and actually get to know
these girls it would be really important
it's not a bad idea Hazel that is a
genuinely brilliant idea yeah I love
talking about my trauma I love tra my
body I just wanted to say I'm loving
what I'm hearing about the club it seems
so supportive of women especially the
hot ones yeah well all women are hot to
me getting a little close to the game
now and um I'm just a bit concerned it
might be taking away attention from our
team no I think that's like literally
impossible to
do we know that the club has been a
place where we can feel empowered
physically the acting in this is so good
they play it like sincere enough they
don't like just go for funny could be a
safe space and a place where we can open
up okay so who's been my God just you
know raise your hand gray area stuff
counts
too all of them everybody knows the
situation with my stepdad he's just
obsessed with Friday movie Nights God I
get it you're my new stepdad whatever
uhhuh every time I call the police about
my stalker they tell me to fill out an
online form and then the form tells me
to call so I call and then they say they
can't get involved until he tries to
kill me yeah everyone knows me for being
beautiful and popular and no one knows
that I'm actually smart like I literally
own a jewelry business and no one talks
about it oh see no what would do my mom
has been doing midlife crisis this has
just been really meaningful to me to
like get to know some new people who
actually want to like get to know me I
just wanted to bring it back to Britney
for one second I go next totally disre
I don't really like talking about juvie
and everything that happened this summer
um I did have to like fight people
basically every single night people were
betting on us we had to just like fight
people sometimes to the death this a lot
more convincing
now I realize now I don't have to be
that person anymore like I I I don't
have to just let things happen to me
because of you guys a I am like really
grateful for what the club has become
and you know from where we started and
such a strange movie I'm going through a
divorce that [__] felt good to say I
tell y'all men need therapy yeah I think
that's a good place to to maybe wrap up
but but not everyone win I don't know
what you're doing tomorrow but I was
going to study for Mr G's women murdered
in history
test so real classes you want to yeah oh
that was
flirtatious just a bit a
mom mom are they playing patty cake up
there what are you doing home so
early is that the the football player
are you kidding me I had a long day Mrs
Callahan can I have a snack huh
interesting
hello ladies I don't know why anyone
wants my old dirty underwear it's so
weird you been to a bikini car wash uh I
don't think so never been to one it was
one once right next door to me and I
didn't go missed opportunity GRE I know
was like than right why didn't you call
me I would have went Britney said she'd
make me a custom bracelet very nice do
you want to um celebrate we could get
some chicken on a stick tonight I can't
Isabelle and I have plans so what you're
hanging out with Isabelle you're
ditching me you're fast fast what are
you talking about my mom was up on like
a meathead what Meathead hi underwear
Jeff you know like the guy it's like the
crybaby with the balls he catches them
and he he throws them course he's like
the main guy the main guy
yes with Jeff I just thought Jeff might
be safeer Jeff is his name you idiot
just get the hot people confused looks
like she's wearing an Ace Ventura they
said they were in juie this summer no
are you sure they're not in the system
she's in a phone book they're taking
away from our popularity so I must check
up on them to see if they're full of
[__]
got it thank you this guy is hysterical
I me you can't take the attention away
from Men We need the attention Okay I
wanted to tell you that um I'm I'm very
glad that I joined the club never been
so happy to get the [__] beaten out of
me I think it's really impressive that
you and PJ went through everything that
you did now have decided to help the
rest of us embrace the light story you
told the other day you're really really
Brave stick to the LIE she's going to
have to learn the truth at some point no
no never I mean you almost killed a girl
you're really really Brave aren't you
two supposed to be studying actually
Isabelle uh there's something you maybe
should know the main guy who you're
dating is cheating on you I heard Jeff
is cheating on you yes that's the
perfect red airing right there who told
you that oh my God she's going to kick
his ass yes yes I want to see that Hazel
told me he and Mrs callah hand are at it
like every night like
constantly oh
God oh
God no no no
no always in their uniforms like cartoon
characters is there a pineapple in this
we about this Jeffrey's allergic to
Pineapple pineapples are worse than
drugs the football players are
Untouchable this is the last
straw
oh I want to see a Revenge of the Nerds
type of stand up against the football
team
yeah she's walking really fast look at
her he's got the m table he's got a
painting a mural of himself are you
having Mrs Callan baby you look so
beautiful are you having with her I'm
I'm I'm helping her with her taxes what
a high school kid helping with taxes are
you cheating on me again again no why
would I why would I do that was one time
with your sister there one oh oh my this
guy is the worst this one time with your
sister I literally saw you yesterday
shut up nerd your mom oh dude what a
dumbass punch him we're
done I love the music in this I'm
getting
revenge up some football players and I'm
buying the G hell yeah oh no what about
like EG yes so we can make them not
refrigerated and smell
like oh no what are you guys doing like
a super small bomb I mean they're super
easy to make and I could just put it
under his car and could be a distraction
everyone can hear you well because the
tone of this movie is not super serious
I think it's
[Music]
okay they are actually going through
this are they really going through
[Music]
this this actually does has a little
feel to the Revenge of the nerd film in
terms of the alpha betas and the jocks
the football team just like running over
the Nerds old film never seen it what
you got to watch
no gento
throats just thr you have to they are
failing at this really bad A for effort
though damn we're uh really going to
scare them
off I think I'm going to help Isabelle
keep watch it's like this weird it's
like a satire of high school movies real
life High School people and fight clip
fight clip people so strange I really
appreciated you fighting and speaking
loudly at my boyfriend I really value
when people use violence and raise their
voices for
me good note it's actually one of my
love
languages okay does anybody know where
the Hazel
is like oh has she planted she actually
doing it I think she's planting the
bombia oh my God 15 seconds
okay
um hurry up hurry
up explosion in the background or in the
foreground it's going to blow oh wow
yeah it's going to blow
guys
[Laughter]
no best getaway ever
[Applause]
I'd be so curious to know how they how
the director worked with the cast
because every it's hard enough getting
two people to have chemistry But like
everyone has good chemistry here great
show last night I don't know what you're
talking about oh you don't no it's
really all good Jeffrey needed a new car
anyway I'm on I'm on to you your Club
you understand it ain't over till I say
it's over some of us clearly have a
different definition of egging but if we
keep our mouth shut stay calm we'll be
fine they're going to shut us down
aren't they what no we don't know that
why Myers will believe whatever Jeff and
Tim say it's not like we talked out loud
about putting a bomb in I'm going to
miss you guys so much at least out with
the bang I mean insane you can still
hang out even if you don't have the club
this club has brought me so much I feel
so much more powerful and protected me
too she look looking directly at Josie
when she said that great oh my God PJ
okay I'm sorry that you didn't get what
you wanted out of this group but I think
the rest of us did oh good foring you
Hazel I'm glad that you finally wrote
one email I practically ran this club
for you and you're so lucky that we
haven't let you be a part of this PJ
you're a liar damn it o there it is you
have no friends and as a mom so dude
letting it all out right now
[Music]
Hazel she's so unnecessarily mean to
her I love
God I love I love God you and PJ really
have been friends forever since the
first grade we had the same babysitter
roads PJ called her gay Yoda but I think
she's kind of like a
mentor you guys like could not not be
more different sitting on her
[Music]
bed
oh first go all the way then tell her
the truth like a
man yeah just embrace the life for
another hour hour yeah they're women
they last longer I was thinking like
just 15 minutes if you're
lucky oh wait no camera panning up tell
her the truth later I'm trying to help
your jewelry business grow yeah I don't
know if I can hire you you're like a
convict wow you're in a room completely
different world I hear that if you hire
a convict they give you a tax
break hate Mr G everything he says is so
pathetic hate people with the last name
that start with G who is Bell Hooks and
why do we care oh sorry I'm just trying
to like study over
here you're wrists are so small and the
pen is so heavy that like is she getting
exhausted I'm surprised you can even see
what you're doing with all the surface
area that yours are taking up wow does
this hurt actually yeah that does hurt
my tiny delicate wrist yeah that was the
lightest T of all time like muscles in
there oh my gosh you're going for
it is she not going to
reciprocate PJ I'm I'm straight oh I was
going to say what would the odds be at
both I'm I'm sorry if you misread
anything it's all good I shouldn't have
assumed anything that is awkward just a
bit no but they have each other yeah for
now maybe by the end of the film she'll
change her mind I wanted to tell you
something no don't tell her right now
read the room read the room like
something that happened no read the room
what happened with is oh she's going to
be so jealous yeah read the room wait
seriously unless this unless she's happy
for her that's that's
amazing trying to be a mature
friend good
[Applause]
[Laughter]
cheer best cheer I've ever
seen stuff happening at Rockbridge Falls
oh is this where they tell the LIE maybe
Andrew how many of you know about that
little girl fight club that could we're
going to bring where is she Hazel D oh
no one of the founding members to show
us everything the club's taught her oh
he
got he got to Hazel well maybe not a
good idea to insult the one person
person in the club that knew everything
yeah we'll be fighting Tucker the
school's number one
B why I thought I was going to be
fighting PJ but don't be alarmed girls
can do anything guys can do right yeah
kick his ass I mean the boxer has way
more
experience no
[__]
[Applause]
nice is she like sort of winning
or damn you may be wondering how a girl
under the training of of two juvie
convicted Killers can't even stand up
for herself against a regular old guy oh
no oh no they didn't go to juvie they
never fought anyone at all and you know
what else they didn't start the club to
empower women they [__] cheer oh [__]
they went all the way with the truth I
thought it was going to be the juvy
[Music]
thing he literally just described
everything guys do lied to get women
oh God poor Hazel they not even
concerned that about hazel the point of
the club is that we all learn from each
other oh no made me do this I didn't
want to I would never want to do this
you're pathetic jie she was lied to
angry with the boy he's really hurt here
though trust broken again you know what
I'm not a idiot I just look like
this I actually was doing this [__] cuz
I actually liked y'all group I trusted
you two and y'all exploited my
solidarity I played the role of an
amazing
Ally is this about the time I said ailia
airart was a fake hero many of guys fly
planes without crashing but you never
hear about them it's so hard to be a
girl we like make less money we have to
lose our last names I love you I want to
be with you for the rest of our life and
all of a sudden you leave me for a
mother named Tony he's talking about his
wife yeah I think that moved away from
her
us like how I'm confused right now on
how you created a Fight Club to get
some I know y'all ain't tickling the
Pearl you know what I'm talking about
you I mean caressing the back of that
neck and all type of Sor I just don't
know if you're supposed to be talking to
us like that just as a
teacher I can't believe Hazel okay well
you were pretty horrible to her
yesterday no don't fall out now you two
The Divide I'm not the one who put
Isabelle on a rampage sorry what does
that have to do with anything if
Isabelle wasn't so desperate to get
revenge then we wouldn't have blown up
Jeff's car and then he wouldn't be so
upset o i just followed your lead like
an idiot you followed my lead when you
created that insane story about girls
betting on you to fight other girls I
mean you follow the lead I got to be
with Isabelle on my own without you no
you never would have talked to her
without me that's true there's a gray
area here
oh we'll have Ari here and we'll so many
girls and whatever you're the only one
who didn't do anything oh [__] well
that's cuz Britney's straight do you
actually like her do you care about
anyone other than yourself just find
some other girl to jack off to and do
nothing about JS the truth will set you
free at first it's going to piss you off
life's like
this are of Broken Dreams that's the way
it is that's the way it is I don't know
why I said Bard brok dream is not chill
out what you will and for it's a of
she's Canadian is
she hey that's better than the other
one I'm I'm not erasing this one sorry
you you don't have my respect anymore if
you think about it like sure it started
off as
like you know to get laid but there's
deeper meaning behind it why all the
presidents have been women make a
mistake and
why it's a great great
commentary no don't go back don't go
back okay I get you're hurt but this
guy's the biggest douchebag
ever come
on I mean when you feel like you have a
lack of selfworth it make you dra back
there's a psychological understanding
here I get that but go to someone
else oh Hazel at least she's got her
buddies here I like that Isabelle was
there with the mom that was banging her
boyfriend yeah it's true if you don't
want to B Firearms then why are you here
like for advice I'm not your gay Yoda
Josie your gay
Yoda when I was in high school people
found out I was gay nobody wanted to be
my friend and back then it was worse
because they hated you just for being
gay not for being gay and
untalent PJ and I are actually in a
fight right now like that's the advice
that I need I never had many friends and
that's that's sad and as I've gotten
older in this world it's just gotten
more sad it's a weird thing where like
it gets more Progressive but gets more
sad at the same time there is a 50-year
rivalry going on they always up some
unlucky place in 77 they burned him at a
steak with his dog in ' 92 they drowned
him in a giant kitty poo what the hell
is this I'm staying inside and double
Bing those doors if you love a girl go
be with the girl now I don't care so I
didn't understand a word of that I'm so
sorry she's so introverted too so I
would love for her to like take center
stage at the football game and like get
everyone back on her side explain the
situation I think that line that she
didn't understand was improvised
probably I really want to see Josie go
on the field and take a microphone and I
saw rhs she says hi by the way she said
this Huntington shit's way darker than
we thought apparently every time
Huntington plays Rockbridge they try to
kill a player and his pets I love this
like random dark nihilism this movie has
you want me and then all of the girls
that hate us I mean the club is together
to get together and save some football
player who we hate why would we do that
because we made these girls trust us and
then we humiliated them they deserve a
shot at showing everybody what they can
do what they learned cool they are this
music sounds like from stranger things
never seen it it's a good show but I
have heard the music on my Pandora
pulling out the necklace in the final
hour best friends for life word I'm
sorry that I called your mom a skank and
I'm sorry for saying that you have no
friends really loud she does have
friends I'm sorry for being an [__] a
lot of the time most
all of the time it's your personality do
you forgive
me forgiveness as a choice yes so I got
information from a very confidential
source that Huntington is trying to kill
someone oh my God nobody is even over
there well that is obviously a red flag
that is bizarre even though you're a
black Republican you are the smartest
out of all of
us I know you really must hate me right
now but the club needs you to what has
with them guys we really really need you
we do in your dreams
[Applause]
PJ I wouldn't be asking you if this
wasn't important we don't have time for
this the red wire blow up a tree hezo
with her
[Applause]
bombs H this is so
bizarre
oh come on God damn it
[Applause]
Hazel hey CL we need to get the
cheerleaders to make out wait okay what
cheerleaders
using oh what is that is that poison rat
poison sulfur guys kiss each other
we
oh golden
Frets love the mood of this oh my God uh
uh I guess this makes sense here need to
cause a
distraction
yeah oh wow now she genuinely feels a
connection here I hope so what what was
maybe that's what all the tension was
always about I'm
gay is she jealous I'm
not I just like
[Laughter]
gay that's a c oh pineapp he's allergic
to pineapples yeah so they're going to
poison Jeff then where the is it what if
it's in their mouths and they're
swishing it around and then they're
going to spit it out mid game what I
hate to say it but it might have
something to do with their obviously at
this
when was this the bomb didn't work oh
the sprinklers they're going to spray
the field what what okay we're going to
have to run we're going to have to run
we're going to have to
[Music]
[Laughter]
run the I got
it let's go let fight
him
yeah Avengers
[Music]
Assemble oh [__] no
wor just scary Jeff I love the Music
Choice
[Music]
whoa oh my
God
yeah get back here you oh my God
no oh she's wanted to kill someone on
film oh no
oh this is
wild nice flying punch
yeah that's right you were saved by a
woman men and woman Banning
together tag
team
oh I love the music so much right now
it's so
good no no don't get the wrong idea Jeff
Jeff stop Jeff oh my God Jeff
oh
you're my night in shining armor
he whoa whoa drop kick him is so
insane
fire pineapple juice it's pineapple
juice it's pineapple juice turn it off
they were
right okay she's the only one she's like
I want Jeff's pineapple juice
later slow
clap respect is not lied about it is
earned this is the Viking
[Applause]
Way everyone just witness a bunch of
murders guy was literally murdered but
Jeff is safe it's all good is
[Applause]
safe white and black gay and straight
all conquered this like Remember the
Titans oh same same it's like the same
movie really proud of you guys a just a
dead guy in the background I feel like
you killed that guy oh yeah I mean we
killed I think we killed you killed that
guy yeah he you've become the story I
just want to say I'm sorry you don't
have to forgive me at all just shut up
and kiss me you know you didn't have to
start like a whole bike Club just to
date me hey worked you could have just
like talk to me H okay uh I don't really
know how true that is you know what I
mean a I like them together they're cute
yeah they're really cute Happy
Valentine's Day reject Nation man I knew
women were good I've been saying that
[__] the whole time
[Applause]
man
oh I got PJ and I got literal tears in
my eyes Andrew this so funny to
[Laughter]
me whoa it worked it worked like CAD
Shack there was a delayed effect like
wait waited till later for a
reference yes damn it that was my
thing by the way what the are you
wearing you got suspenders over your
like a goddamn
freak there's got to be so many takes of
improv that was so well edited it's
going to be fine he's so preoccupied
with his
deor yeah I drank before I came to class
what sorry and this is PHS 80s too
showing out takes like this in the
[Applause]
[Music]
credits y'all were two of my top
students I think oh no that was two
other students but at the end of the day
it don't matter this [__] is like Beyond
me not beyond meat
like hey guys hey guys
hi hey
guys how old are you I put whiskey in
that actually dealing with the DW d
no dinosaurs depression these
[Applause]
nuts yes
yes very
nice they went with the last one being
the joke that they thought was so like
juvenile big thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video a real game
changer I've been using for years that's
right years so whenever they want to
work with us it's an instant yes you've
likely heard about expressvpn for Online
private see in security but there's more
to it than that however there was a very
real incident recently with Spectrum
showing down my internet and contacting
me due to a suspecting hacking attempt
and funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
cinema at your fingertips it's super
easy open Express VPN switch locations
refresh the browser and there you have
it whether it's kdramas on South Korean
Netflix Hulu BBC I player YouTube or
more expressvpn has you cover and it's
incredibly fast ensuring no buffering or
lack for smooth HD streaming it's
versatile too working on not just
computers but phones media consoles
Smart TVs and more this means you can
enjoy your favorite shows on anywhere
any screen protect and elevate your
internet experience so if you want to
get access to hundreds of new shows use
my link expressvpn.com Rejects and you
can get an extra 3 months of expressvpn
for free that's
expressvpn.com reex so head to
expressvpn.com reex to learn more thank
you again thrilled to be partnering with
a brand I've been using for nearly 2
years now and that's Harry's Razors I'm
generally more drawn to anything that
goes against the norm and Harry's does
just that in The Grooming World they saw
the high prices in the industry and
decided to blaze their own trail with
quality and afford ability I keep a beer
but whenever you see these cheeks in the
neck clean and that's the work of
Harry's right there keeps my wife happy
and Harry's makes it effortless they're
Precision Blades that cut smoothly with
less drag making every shave satisfying
and yes it's versatile
for other areas too you know what I mean
so as a Harry's devota can vouch for
their value you can experience
unparalleled comfort and quality in your
grooming routine where exceptional
craftsmanship meets affordability making
a smart choice for a top- notot shave
without breaking the bank their kits and
value packs for shaving are unbeatable
but Harry's is is not just about shaving
again they offer top quality
thoughtfully designed grooming products
including shampoo conditioner and
amazing body wash without the premium
price quality affordability that's a
thesis of this now these I actually
pulled right from my own bathroom I
regularly use their five blade razor
with a nice weighted handle and they
foaming shaved gel man this that oh it
is a game Cher I just like the feel of
it now I have to commit to keeping this
in my hand the whole time cuz I'm not
going to go to the bathroom in the
middle of shooting this the handles they
feel perfectly balanced and the razor
Sleek design is a classy addition to my
bathroom and the quality of the shave
unparalleled got to reiterate key part
of my weekly grooming ritual cuz their
entire range of products fits seamlessly
into my routine definitely no re-shoot
here their German engineer blades are
durable and refill plans are economical
rarely use the word economical but I'm
using it now plus their commitment to
high customer satisfaction and no risk
trial makes Harry's a no-brainer this
Joel really does feel good let me say
once more choosing Harries means quality
and affordability by grabbing your $13
trial set for just $3 at harry's.com
reex you're not only getting a great
deal but you're also supporting this
channel that's harry's.com reex for your
$3 trial set stay sharp and embrace the
extraordinary with Harry till next time
reject Nation till next time thank you
so much to our sponsors they help cover
everything around here and it's a great
way to support the channel by supporting
them as well ladies and gentlemen uh we
just watched the movie bottoms and
before going into this I did not know it
was viol
okay did not know it was going to be
violent I heard it was funny and I tend
to go in with a bit of an apprehension
espe when people are like it's a really
funny movie and I'm very fortunate I
didn't see the trailer for this so it
was a very
unexpected
Journey and I thought it was just going
to be kind of a straightforward High
School comedy film that would be runchy
that's all I thought it was going to be
and as it progressed I saw we were in a
completely different different terrain
because while it does follow some you
know uh certain plot beats and and
conventional Trope outlines that you
would sort of expect a movie like this
genre to go uh it's more about execution
of what really makes that unique and it
it's a real easy comparison to go yeah
this is like Fight Club meets you know
super bad right like that's the way you
would do it's PR of the movies pretty
much laying that out for you that it's
Fight Club meet super bad with a lot of
current things that they are making fun
of that feel very modern and that's what
I loved about it because it takes the
piss out of like uh feminism toxic
masculinity yes the whole she a bunch of
like cliches in high school just all the
all the commentary all around but more
importantly than all of that like you
you watch a movie like this for a couple
of things is do you do you like the
characters and is it funny and those two
main things that you walk into here uh I
thought it more than delivered
on here the the thing that I would say
that really I think distinguishes it
from I think there's been like kind of a
rise and runchy kind of Comedy lately
again because if you think about it like
you just reacted to 22 Jump Street here
on the channel right and a lot of people
consider that the last big just
full-blown comedy a a movie that was
just a comedy you know now it's a movie
where comedy is sort of secondary or
comedy is adjacent in some way the last
time a movie was just pitched as a
comedy that is a huge hit and uh some
people often make the argument for 22
Jump Street being that one I'm sure
there's other ones in the mix but like
we've had no hard feelings come out we
had Joy Ride and those movies did not
really do the box office numbers that
they would hope for I don't really know
how this did but I know this one was a
big conversation at least and I I think
what's really great about is
particularly this one that I think
stands out from when you compare it to
like super bad or those Jud Apo movies
from the day is I would like it in more
to like a 21 Jump Street type of comedy
in the sense of how it feels very
thought out uh very composed H you know
like the director you could feel that
they got a real DP involved the real
Director of Photography to help create
some type of look and feel and symmetry
to it as opposed to get a bunch of
talented actors together improvise know
where you want these beats to land in
the scene and then slap together in the
editing room because one thing I could
not tell when watching this other than a
few times is I really have no clue what
is improvised and what is written cuz it
it was so sharp so solid and this is
such a tight film at the same time I was
really impressed with it and especially
it's commitment to the violence when you
have like the Cara they're all played by
adults uh but when they're playing you
know teen you know uh female teen ladies
teen girls and they're they're
committing to the violent acts I I think
that when you commit to violence in a
movie like a comedy it it makes it
funnier yeah when it goes that dark with
the violence so I was really impressed
with this movie uh by a lot there's more
specifics to dive into but that's my
general General like going in from
pre-ww watching it to watching after
just watching it now by the way if you
are listening to us on Apple or Spotify
if you don't mind giving us a rating it
would really help us out we would really
appreciate it keep me in check Andy yeah
that's what I'm here for Greg um but yes
no I I did not know what to expect as I
had never heard of this film um but uh
the thing that I appreciated the most
besides like the style of you know
infusing the 80s style and and then also
super bad Meats uh Fight Club and then I
like the comparison you make with 2122
jumpster I think that's good uh just the
whole the camaraderie between the group
and the female empowerment I thought it
was done it wasn't like forced and
jammed down your throat because there
was all you know this um you know let's
worship the men and the football players
type of stuff and you know it was a good
lesson to be had here and that is you
know um if you seek uh you know
relationship status with the ones you uh
achiev to be with lie and make up a
fight club you know that's I I
appreciated the lesson that but no in
all seriousness I I really did like the
lessons in this film and also too like U
uh the chemistry between uh the two
actresses who played PJ and Josie they
were so fantastic you could really feel
the history between those two and how
much they bonded the contrast between
them just as characters and just how
much they cared for each other and
obviously it made the Divide when that
uh when they had the falling out all the
more heartbreaking cuz we were so
invested at that point with those two
characters uh but in such an interesting
style too just from I mean again that 21
type jumpstream and then you got a lot
of Darker moments like of trying to
poison with the pineapple juice and all
and blowing up cars and all that so I
thought thought it was really well
balanced with the tone um so that's why
I didn't mind like doing more of the the
runchy and the dark stuff it it all for
me personally it's all about balance and
I thought like this film did a really
good job with the balance um but acting
wise such great performances and like
you said I could never tell when they
were improvising but at the same time
I'm like it it was very impressive at
the same time like I I can only imagine
how much improving was going on at the
same time but uh interesting choice too
that they went with marshan I thought he
did a great job um in the film as well
um as the teacher like you know cuz he
had he had some I mean what what I think
this film did a good job of highlighting
is just like everyone's uh baggage that
they had that they were dealing with
like obviously you know with the two
main characters they were in love and
they had to find some kind of way to you
know get their their Love's attention
and with uh marshan Lynch's and
obviously with hazel you know she had
the issues with her mother and then the
other girl had issues with her
stepfather and then with marshan Lynch
he obviously was having problems with
his uh wife so I think the film did just
a really good job highlighting those
issues and then you know uh again just
like the even though a lie brought them
all together um I just thought it was
just done in a methodical way and just a
beautiful emotional way to you know that
just uh made me very invested in these
characters and I just I love the the
script so much I can only imagine too
like if I was an actor reading the
script I'm like
where the hell is this script going like
it would have been a little confusing to
me personally I mean I'm not as smart as
most of y'all but um or these actors but
I would have been like I have no idea
what the tone is for this film I would
have just uh had to have a meeting with
the director and been like okay I trust
your vision and uh I'm going to go with
you on this one well yeah they genre
they genr spice it a lot you know
because it it is a it is a dark comedy
as well as sometimes just being a flat
out hilarious you know Coming of Age
teen comedy because I think the movie is
very is quite endearing it is quite
heartfelt and a times uh really pushes
the envelope with its sensibilities with
its sense of humor and to your point you
know about like yeah I'll start with the
with a li I think what this movie did so
well is they they really gave us
characters they didn't just get some
people are more fleshed out than others
as as it goes and some people you get
more back and whatnot and one of the
comments I was making while watching it
is yes like the chemistry between uh Io
Io adiri and Rachel sonot I don't know
son I don't know if there's a silent
there or not the chemistry between them
so good most important one you got to
nail down automatically uh but as a
collective as a group and then even when
you would have um them interact with the
men or or other side characters the way
way the interactions were done everyone
had chemistry like the whole cast had
chemistry even with with characters you
you put together in a room where you
don't even think that they would need
chemistry but they do like everyone
bounces off of each other so well in a
way that never felt perfunctory or
forced and with that whole thing
starting with a lie it's like yeah they
say like on the surface is you know we
want to get
laid however you could they also fles
out that they're very lonely people like
they they only have each other they're
like they're bullied and stuff so a lot
of it also does come down to what they
really want is that that moment when
they're in the circle and they're all
talking to each other about what their
their troubles are at home or
experiences they've had uh via assault
or whatever like that's really what they
wanted and the movie made that clear so
like while again certain certain aspects
do play out with conventional tropes um
like with like yeah you know these two
are going to like fall in love you know
what some lessons are going to be
learned you know they're going to have
that beat where the two main characters
are going to temporarily not be friends
with each other like that's the way
these comedies tend to go uh it's the
it's the structure of it it's when we
get there it like is the impact still
there though is the are the emotions
still felt and I think this movie did a
really good job at remembering to still
give you fleshed out characters and to
not just play the comedy and cuz
sometimes s in in certain films like
that you could feel characters like
let's just cat's Comedians and let's
just have them go for the funny and to
my understanding uh I would the be is
she's a comedian uh but like man there's
such a such a heartfelt performance she
knows that the key to being funny here
like it seemed like what's this is what
everyone knew was to play it straight to
play it to with with sincerity and to
not like amp it up to like try to sell
the comedy you know and I and I think
that's because they because the movie is
also willing
to um take the piss out of everyone in a
way without being they they never seem
preachy about anything they're talking
about like they're never telling the
audience here's the message you need to
take away here's what you need to learn
you know like they boil it down to this
the Simplicity of of of uh of of PE of
you know tell being honest and kinship
and all that and but at the same time
like they they do make fun of even like
the the men in the world who uh you know
try to act like they're they the strong
male Advocate you know that's like kind
of mar tough testost like try to be that
but then you see where a lot of the
mistakes my falter how quickly people
are to back woman but if a mistake
happens no women are wrong like they
they do a lot and they also make fun of
menal a lot and and I think though that
they keep it grounded in the world and
what the characters are experiencing and
then the movie doesn't ever stop to go
let's just talk about what we want to
talk about they always keep it in the
characters and that's why I think the
commentary doesn't it like the
commentary never overshadows the journey
you know what I mean yeah uh it's just
fun and and the commentary that they
make is stuff that we hear people make
fun of all the time or have serious
debates and arguments about all the time
H but they know how to infuse it in a
way where it just kind of they they
created a there's that's I think that's
what I need to boil it down to it's a
comedy that created a world you know for
sure for sure and also too I like how
you were during the reaction pointing
out like some of the psychological
effects uh that we were talking about
too like for instance like with Isabelle
where obviously you know she really had
fallen for Josey and then once the LIE
had been uh told now I'm like wait why
is she going back with Jeff like dude
cheated on you twice once with your
sister and once with uh one of your
members of your group's mother and then
you're like well you know she's dealing
with a psychological trauma now and like
you know when you're in a point like
that and so I thought that that was an
interesting highlight as well that they
were uh going over so like you said I
just thought that the film just you know
went over a lot of different things that
I really appreciated um you know dealing
with what we go with now what also
paying homage to a lot of things that we
liked you know whether 80s uh type of
film stylization or uh and again the
genre of mix of uh film style making
that I Lov but uh we're going to read
some trivia facts and yeah yeah I think
everyone's just so good in this movie
you know like I know it's really well
really well made even like the Havana
Rose Lou as Isabelle I liked Hazel a lot
too Hazel was great Ruby Cruz was
amazing like everyone was so and even K
Gerber again a character who shows up
and you're like okay you're the hot one
but then they give her more to do than
just be the hot one and on top of that
too she's really good in the fil she
gotu where she's like I've got a jewelry
business everyone's like exactly yeah no
no yeah looking under the surface and
one thing that I was surprised the movie
didn't do and maybe I missed a line or
two cuz sometimes like comedy was
happening so fast right is uh I like how
they didn't like play into race that
much like people's
ethnicities because even though it's a
it's very diverse in terms of its
casting like yes we got the queer
representation on full display here uh
but it's not about representation in
that sense like it's just it's such a
natural way of including it and that
doesn't call attention to it and that's
my favorite kind of representation cuz
it's it's like all mainly women and you
know you got an ethnically diverse cast
but it's never about like hey you're
Asian or you know you're you're black or
something like that and I I like how
they just keep it about the characters
and um and what's relevant to them in
that moment I thought it was really I
thought it was really funny even the guy
play Jeff was hilarious oh miles Fowler
to as the other guy everyone was so good
this is a really great cast very well
casted most the other guy too who played
uh what was the other football player I
thought he was well casted too the one
who's like hazel uh oh yeah his name is
that one's miles Fowler he's the guy
who's uh the I think so right he's the
Oh I thought miles Fowler was Jeff
no I could be wrong actually let's look
it up before I make big doooo here yeah
I could be wrong no Andrew I could be
wrong no yeah okay see I was wrong miles
fower is Tim yeah yeah seen is Jeff yeah
yeah but I thought they were both so
well casted um and also too I love like
he again very much so like many males
crave attention and I just thought that
was like the focal point of his
character I thought it was hysteric see
Revenge of the Nerds I and The Breakfast
Club yeah Hazel um reminded me a lot of
uh she she seemed like a more
extroverted version of the basket case
yeah let us know in the comments section
if you want Greg and someone else on the
team to react to revenge on their I want
to see Craig see that I want to watch it
Mara Lynch was initially unsure about
accepting the role he ended up taking it
as a way to rewrite his regret of
mishandling his younger sister coming
out to him in high school oh nice you
did it Marshon Lynch improvised most of
his lines I yeah I could from the
outakes I could I could see that oh oh
the people who played uh the two main
leads were roommates when they okay yeah
their chemistry was like unmatched that
one makes sense yeah we even said in the
first 5 minutes we're like damn they got
some insane good chemistry makes total
sense now and Emma Salinger the Seligman
the director and WR and and writer um
good okay so yeah that's what an
interesting story because I know um just
because we talked about Jed AO earlier I
know Jed AO and uh Adam Sandler they
were actually roommates as well oh
really yep according Emma saligman when
summer Joy Campbell Sylvie filmed her
line yes Queen SLE she was so committed
the scene that she ruined her voice
after screaming so hard oh
damn uh okay the instrumental meat used
for the cheers pep rally dance is a
parody of Toxic by Britney Spears makes
sense okay all right I'm assuming facts
it's always like that with the newer
movies it's kind of hard to get like the
big facts out there
spoilers spoilers by the way Jo's
talking to the Club at her fake juvie
experience she's actually recounting the
plot of The Hungry Games oh damn I
missed I didn't even catch that Jesus I
missed that what the
hell uh it's a replica of what oh the
final battle repli Club the lord of the
rigs man how did I not notice that I got
to turn in my nerd card hey IO add edber
is actually allergic to pineapples oh
really interesting sitting like the 12
supper uh the the L Adventures painting
painting of the 12 when we saw the meral
in the background yeah yeah yeah yeah
the level on screen violence with the
severity of the injuries increases as
the film progresses that's why I love it
that's why I love it yes that uh that
first injury though got me I was like it
set the toe and she barely hit with the
thing he just Falls and like it was
hilarious I really enjoy I really
enjoyed it was a lot of fun and then
again I just I I love the the tone and
the balance of the tone and again the
Chemistry Between the two main leads and
the camaraderie of the group and just
again the sincerity of the film really
enjoyed it guys leave your thoughts down
below what did you think about bottoms
did you enjoy it as much as us uh leave
a like subscribe thank you to our
sponsors for this video and we will talk
with you all soon peace out reject
[Music]
Nation